um but yeah i gotta play a little bit of
uh plaguetail requiem it is
uh very much more plague tale um
it's kind of a weird game to demo
because i feel like plague tales so much
about the
that narrative and getting invested in
the characters and like what's happening
so they're just like they throw you into
like chapter three and you're like i
have
okay still loads of rats
tons of rats the rat tech is still on
point have they have they trademarked
rat tech yet because i would i want to
see the game opened with a logo for rat
heck
yeah oh like a like speed tree situation
yeah
yeah um yeah rat tech is good uh those
rats are just
everywhere um
it doesn't feel as big of a like
generational leap as the first one i
would say um like it's definitely gonna
look better and play better but as
someone who like just recently played uh
innocence like last year on the series x
i was like this looks fairly comparable
to what the the first one did i'm sure
like some of the
uh like character models and fidelity
looks better um
did it get
uh series x upgrades
yes and that's how i played it it's a
very good version of that game yeah so
it's a great game i really enjoyed it
and it picks up where the last game left
off right
yes um
so i guess
slight spoilers for the end of
plaguetail
but like innocence innocence i must say
don't you dare spoil this game for me
john luke i know it on the ending
but uh
at the end of that game they're like oh
we're they basically just like leave
whatever place they're in and they're
like we gotta go find safety and then
you are in this
town
i'm not sure are they still in france i
think so there's a town of rattenberg or
something like that i want this game no
i was gonna be like is it a town overrun
by cats like for safety
oh that's fine that'd be smart
yeah radam
what if that was like
like we can only defeat these rats with
an equally large number of like evil
cats
that would be amazing
no so you
yeah they're like in this town and uh
hugo the little kid is like ill so you
have to go find some night shade for him
and then and so uh amicia and lucas are
like heading off to go
find him um find him that like
nightshade
uh
just bad shit's happening constantly um
the
part of the town is uh
infected with rats but the guards aren't
telling anyone and they're just
murdering everyone in that like area to
keep it contained um
eventually you like so you kind of like
go through this sort of quarantined area
and then you come out into like the
countryside because you're trying to
find this um
like herbalist who's got the medicine
and i would say
the interesting thing
that they did was
they
for the most part the gameplay feels
very much the same you know it's like
okay like yep i got my slingshot i got
my pots i can um throw
uh like ex extinguish or whatever it's
called igneous no igneous is the one
this is one that turns up lights on fire
you can light on fire and then it's like
extinguish i don't know they sound like
harry potter um spells
pocket sound
basically yeah you're like pocket sand
uh so you can like you know uh
disable the lights or the the torches
and then like the rats just eat everyone
um
the whole thing in this one is like
this is like uh amusing is like last of
us part two where it's like oh she's
like jaded she's grizzled she's angry
yeah
pinch
every time you kill someone should be
like yeah you dogs that's what you
deserved and then like lucas is like
chill out like what the
what is going on so
does the combat and gameplay kind of
reflect her more aggressive experience
side because i remember a big part of
plague tale innocence as it was called
was like her loss of innocence and how
she kind of becomes a cold-blooded
killer because like
yeah i'm curious how the game plays
itself yeah at least in this slice it
was mostly very much the same like you
you still have to be very stealthy like
you're going to get um like killed right
away but they added some interesting
mechanics like there's now a counter
system where you can actually kind of
like push a guy away from you so it's
like she's kind of got a little more
like she's a little more feisty yeah she
don't have a knife you're not like
sneaking up on people and like stabbing
their throats and [ __ ] no no you can't
there is a knife you do get a knife and
you can go up and straight up stab
people but it's like a one time
it is a one-time use knife though so you
it's like the shiv's in last about yeah
it's a little more strategic well that's
kind of nice i know because you've only
used it once yeah
i see you've played knife's boonie
before
is there is there a greater focus on
combat i couldn't really in the gameplay
thing that showed up today like there
was it was mostly combat i'm like oh i
kind of missed the
more puzzle
like stealth yeah there's still plenty
of that and in fact like kind of one of
the culminating areas in the demo was
this section where you um
kind of you have to like get through
this huge group of enemies and you
definitely have to stealth it but it
felt like it felt a little more open
than the previous games where it
actually was like oh there's clearly
multiple different paths i could take
and it's like oh i could hide behind
here if like a guy shows up or i could
go this way so it seems like they're
trying to expand just sort of like the
um
like the areas themselves and it's not
just like this linear straight shot
which is good um like through each area
where it's like there's very clearly
like
the right way to do it like it felt a
little more open which i thought was
cool um and then at the end of the demo
there is this whole section where like
amisi is like oh i'm screw this i'm like
i'm over this and you just straight up
have this like showdown where you kill
like 20 guards geez
and i like what they're doing with it i
will say some of the voice acting from
her got like a little goofy um she's
putting on her like
batman voice when she was trying to
sound like intense so she's like
i'm just tired of this lucas i need to
kill them all like she was like put on
this gravelly voice and i'm like origin
story french is first
this just kind of reads a little more
hokey than like
part of it's the accent too because i
know they all have french accents so i
wonder if like that kind of factors into
it a little
like i just kind of found it a little
more silly than like serious i was like
okay all right
but she's got a crossbow in this one
yeah i didn't get to use the crossbow or
anything so i think that's the
interesting stuff because i feel like
that is where they would get more into
like combat combat right and like really
wanting to because it was still very
much like slingshot you can only hit the
guys if they don't have the helmets on
yeah that kind of thing so yeah i think
overall i'm just super curious how the
combat progression is gonna be because i
felt like that was so meaningful in the
first game in terms of how you kind of
become the master of the environment
you're able to use the rats to help
fight things with you and i know lucas
is sick so he's not or not lucas the kid
hugo hugo is sick so he's not with you
to do that kind of stuff but i'm curious
like how you
how you progress the game play with a
character who's like already
ready to kill and like i guess it's
getting a crossbow which
the natural progression yeah which
doesn't feel as natural
did you watch the gameplay live stream
thing that they did that happened no i
didn't get around to it i would say
there's just this moment where like she
uh mistia is just so hurt that she just
turns to hugo and she's like no it's
okay go for it do it we have to and he
takes control of the rats and you use
the rats to just kill everyone there so
like
part
controlling the rats
dc
yeah like yeah like the dc here like
it's controlling the rats and directing
them to like kill everyone there so i
think there will be a part of the game
where like hugo is i think i complete
the original does he like become rat man
essentially
the rat king yeah
i do not remember yeah
you have like a
it's very brief there's a showdown with
like a priest yeah they didn't quite
land there he has the white rats and you
have the black rats and there's some
weird like racial
just going for like a last of us kind of
like tone like is it gonna end with
omesia like trying to drown a rat and
crying at the same time or something
what it feels like i hope so
i don't know yeah like the pied piper
comes in
no i want i want the abbey uh early
fight but with a mesia and a rat like
half a frame by frame
like like a dark souls bloodborne giant
that's kind of cinematic where they're
like fighting and amicia is trying to
drown the rat and rat gets upper hand
and tries to drown her and it's just
like so halfway through you get to play
the rat yeah excellent oh yeah that'd be
good perspective yeah that would be
pretty sick i'd play that game
um someone in chat asked is there a time
jump from end of first game to i'm not
actually sure because because again the
demo started me oh yeah and part way
through the game
hit puberty no he doesn't look that much
i was gonna say it it's gotta only be
like a few months okay if if that like
there's yeah not like a serious time
skip are you excited about this having
finished oh yeah i'm very excited about
it i mean like i said
as a demo it's a little more like yep
this plays like the first game a couple
changes um for me it's more just like i
really got invested in those characters
in that world
so i'm like i just kind of want to see
where the story goes
um but the gameplay was never like
i don't know like the gameplay was good
but it was never the strongest part of
the game like it felt like it could use
more improvement and i will say that
like what i saw in the demo felt more of
the same so i'm like a little like i was
kind of hoping it to be a little bit
more um but also it's still like a very
early slice like i don't have the
crossbow yet maybe the crossbow changes
everything yeah yeah as crossbows doing
games i've learned anything introducing
a bow or a crossbow into a game that's
that's that's that's me that's the
mechanic that's brotherhood they've
added a crossbow best assassin far cry
far cry 3. let's throw a cross or let's
throw a bow and arrow in here change the
game yup yup
uh i think the the the game the first
game was such a surprise for a lot of
people oh yeah that i kind of i'm
interested to see where they go with it
because then when you have that
situation you're like we can either
stick close to what we unexpectedly
delivered on or we can try and do
something different
um i hope that they
it doesn't stick too close and it seems
like some of the stuff that they showed
off already was like we're gonna keep it
familiar but there is opportunity to
kind of expand a bit more on it and my
hope is that they do that because just
another one of these games will probably
be fine but it feels like they built so
much goodwill with that original game
that they this is a good moment for them
to leverage that and be like hey we're
more than just a one-trick pony like
one yeah
yeah so fingers crossed for that is
there a release for it yet they
announced it today october
15th
18th
do they have a cool like um pining pun
for it as well like rat day is
hashtag
you